l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que notre séance et
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
notre site internet
chacun observera à la fois son temps et
le respect des uns et des autres et nous
sommes dans la journée ou à l'initiative
de madame la secrétaire d'état
cherchez les personnes handicapées nous
vivons duo cette journée et je voudrais
saluer dans la tribune virginie henry
r'mel que nous accueillons dans le cadre
de cette diodé que nous partageons ici
entre le gouvernement et le sénat
la parole est à notre collègue jean yves
roux pour le rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues la
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
il ya quelques semaines à la suite du
grand débat le président de la
république a annoncé les grandes lignes
d'un nouvel acte de la décentralisation
une pièce au répertoire d'apparence
classique pour nous sénateurs mais qui
ne manque pas de susciter l'inquiétude
des principaux acteurs les collectivités
locales
aujourd'hui cette pièce n'est pas encore
à la fiche mais déjà les rumeurs
bruissent et le ballet des suppositions
don de quelque peu le tournis il
s'agirait ainsi je cite monsieur le
ministre des collectivités locales de
faire une décentralisation qui repartent
du citoyen et non des élus ou de l'état
expression qui mériterait sans doute
quelques explications
madame la ministre comme vous le savez
bien les collectivités locales
en quelques années du et sue et su
s'adapter au gré des réformes changement
le périmètre des intercommunalités ou
des communes changement de compétences
délégation de compétence baisses de
dotations ont été réalisés dans des
délais parfois très cool ou peu adapté
aux réalités locales et ces réformes ont
mobilisé beaucoup d'énergie et
d'inquiétude
elles ont laissé des traces chez les
élus dans les administrations parmi les
citoyens aussi madame la ministre si ce
nouvel acte d'ampleur de la
décentralisation il y à nous plus
d'hommes pour lever vite des principales
interrogations car c'est l'incertitude
constituent des freins pour les projets
locaux et des fremm pour
l'investissement
d'où plaidera ce titre pour un
calendrier très précis nous plus
d'hommes pour que la question des moyens
et de la fiscalité locale soient
examinés en même temps nous plaidons
aussi pour que les collectivités soient
confortés ému identifié deux le rôle
nous plaidons pour la préservation d'un
maillage de proximité qu'est la
calendrier proposé vous quelles méthodes
proposées vous et quelle france des
territoires voulez vous je vous remercie
on veut répondre la parole est à madame
la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales madame
jacqueline gourault merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur jean yves
roux
comme vous le savez lors du grand débat
et notamment les réunions entre le
président de la république et les élus
locaux
il y a eu de la part des élus des
demandes de nouvelle décentralisation et
le président de la république
conformément à tout ce qu'il a entendu
sur le territoire a annoncé un nouvel
acte de décentralisation le 25 avril
pour être très précise et il a cité
trois domaines il a cité le logement les
transports ou la transition écologique
cette évolution pour répondre à votre
question monsieur le sénateur s'appuiera
sur des principes clairs qui sont
responsabilité lisibilité et financement
je crois que le triptyque est nécessaire
sur ce fondement j'entends ainsi
identifiés au sein de ses shows les
compétences susceptibles d'être confiée
aux collectivités territoriales cette
évolution se fera bien entendu en
étroite collaboration avec les
associations d'élus locaux et je précise
aussi avec les élus sur les territoires
et je m'apprête bien sûr a lancé un
cycle des changes avec l'ensemble des
élus pour discuter à partir du mois de
juin nous allons attendre la fin bien
sûr de la période électorale il
m'appartiendra aussi je tiens à le
préciser
un travail très interministériel puisque
naturellement il y a par exemple
logement qui fait partie de mon
ministère met les transports la
transition écologique sont transversales
et il faut aussi qu'avec l'ensemble de
mes collègues nous fassions un travail
commun pour présenter et pour débattre
avec les élus locaux
au-delà de ces éléments de méthode
ce nouvel acte de décentralisation devra
permettre de définir également la
politique de contractualisation avec les
collectivités
c'est local dans les matières qui le
nécessitent
j'ajoute aussi que nous discuterons du
droit à la différenciation dans la
réforme constitutionnelle qui va venir
ces champions ces chantiers doivent
s'articuler bien sûr avec l'existant et
il n'y a pas je dirais de grands
changements au sens bouleversement c'est
ce que vous me demandiez mais un travail
commun à construire ensemble
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue cécile cukierman pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes avaient la parole la sherco
le président à monsieur mise intérieur
mes chers collègues le 9 mai dernier le
conseil constitutionnel a rendu une
décision historique en validant de
manière incontestable
la première mise en oeuvre d'un
référendum d'initiative partagée
c'est ainsi la privatisation des
aéroports de paris bradage d'un service
public national qui devrait être soumis
au vote de nos concitoyennes et de nos
concitoyens rappelons que cette
procédure
rv est tellement d'embûches pour sa mise
en place qu'en 2008 lors de son
inscription dans la constitution
personne ne croyait vraiment à sa
réalisation
il aura donc fallu l'exaspération sursis
suscité par la politique d' emmanuel
macron un ultralibéralisme désordonnée
dogmatique pour permettre de franchir
cette première étape maintenant 4,7
millions d'électrices et d'électeurs
doivent approuver cette procédure
référendaire pour que le cheminement
démocratique se poursuivre c'est vous
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur qui
selon l'article 3 de la loi organique de
2013 on 114 du 6 décembre 2013 devait
mettre en oeuvre sous le contrôle du
conseil constitutionnel
le recueil des soutiens apportés à une
proposition de loi soumise à référendum
c'est pourquoi huit parlementaires dont
cinq présidents de groupes représentant
226 députés sénateurs ont souhaité vous
rencontrer pour examiner avec vous les
conditions
de la plus large participation à cet
événement citoyen or à ce jour et par
courrier vous avez refusé de les
recevoir les renvoyant au président du
conseil constitutionnel
cette attitude est inacceptable car
c'est vous qui aurez la responsabilité
technique la responsabilité politique du
bon déroulement de cette consultation
monsieur le ministre s l'excès de
consultations du peuple qui mine nos
institutions ou la remise en cause
systématique des votes et espérance
populaire vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe castaner le président
mesdames messieurs sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vous avez raison respecter les
votes populaires est toujours un sujet
qui doit nous rassembler aujourd'hui
madame la sénatrice rappelé rappeler
ceux qui aujourd'hui amène le ministre
de l'intérieur à répondre à votre
question effectivement le 9 mai le
conseil constitutionnel a déclaré
conforme la proposition de loi visant à
affirmer le caractère de service public
national de l'exploitation delhaize de
l'aérodrome de paris vous avec pour cela
il faut rassembler 4 millions 717 1396
électeurs inscrits sur la liste
électorale et il appartient au conseil
constitutionnel d'organiser la
vérification du bon déroulement de cette
collecte collecte de signatures et le
ministère de l'intérieur agit dans ce
cadre là sous l'autorité sous l'autorité
du conseil constitutionnel comme un
opérateur et madame la sénatrice ne
voyait pas dans ma réponse qui a rappelé
ce bon système qui sous l'autorité du
conseil continue permet d'avancer et
j'ai transmis immédiatement votre
demande celle des prises en groupe au
président du conseil constitutionnel
pour l'irc évidemment comme je l'aï
indiqué dans mon courrier je me tenais à
sa disposition et en fonction de sa
décision dès lors que le ministère de
l'intérieur agit pour son compte
j'aurais évidemment l'occasion de
préparer et de présenter tous les
documents qu'il sollicitera et y compris
de rencontrer les présidents de groupe
mais madame la sénatrice rappeler ce qui
est un bon principe de fonctionnement
est rappelé que le ministère de
l'intérieur n'a pas vocation à court
circuiter le conseil constitutionnel
dans la mise en oeuvre de la bonne
consultation citoyenne sur ce sujet
ça n'est nullement faire insulte à la
démarche et encore moins aux présentes
groupe madame la sénatrice qui m'ont
écrit mais il est évident qu il
appartient au conseil constitutionnel de
déclarer si la proposition a obtenu ou
non un soutien d'au moins un dixième des
électeurs et c'est dans ce cadre là que
nous devons agir sachez madame la
sénatrice que avant même que le conseil
constitionnel prenne sa décision
nous avions préparé les dispositions
techniques pour pouvoir la mettre en
oeuvre sa décision est aujourd'hui
confirmée et nous serons prêts dans le
délai d'un mois pour ouvrir la
consultation pendant le délai neuf mois
nécessaires merci je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
didier marie pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain vous avez la parole le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues dans dix jours les
français éliront leurs députés européens
le gouvernement est massivement entrée
en campagne cela se voit les ministres
sont sur tous les fronts dans tous les
territoires
cela s'entend les belles paroles et les
promesses se multiplient on a ainsi
entendu parler d'un tournant vers de
monsieur macron lors de la présentation
de votre programme
un tournant car ce n'était pas jusqu'à
présent votre plus grand marqueur
politique ni européen ni nationale comme
à l'échelle européenne
le vide de la dernière déclaration de
six bus est l'exemple même du manque
d'ambition concrète de la france sur le
climat alors que l'accord de paris a été
notre honneur en 2015 et si la
république en marche promet aujourd'hui
une banque européenne du climat le
président de la république qui siège au
conseil européen ne l'a jamais évoqué
avec ses pairs en deux ans au niveau
national les trous dans la raquette sont
également nombreux
ne prenons aucun exemple récent la
suppression annoncée d'un train pour
transporter les fruits et légumes de
perpignan à rungis
résultat 25 mille camions de plus par an
sur les routes
nous sommes loin du met ko planète great
games votre programme évoque aussi un
tournant social et démocratique des
notions qui font écho au discours de la
sorbonne c'était il ya un an et demi et
les actes se font toujours attendre
pire ce sont des signaux contraires qui
ont été envoyés par le président la
république lorsqu'il s'oppose est en
première ligne aux avancées sociales et
démocratiques européennes
à l'image des directives lanceur d'alert
malmené et congé parental torpillé par
la france alors comment expliquez vous
monsieur le ministre le décalage entre
ce programme est ce que vous avez
réalisé depuis deux ans pour vous
répondre
la parole est aux milices d'état maëlys
de la transition écologique et solidaire
monsieur de rugy merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur mari
d'abord je vous le confirme
oui nous nous engageons pour la
construction européenne et moi je suis
très fier voyez vous d'ailleurs ce soir
je serai dans le tarn et je vais en
effet sur plusieurs points du territoire
par tous défendent la construction
européenne il est de bon ton de nos
jours de crier haro sur l'europe est de
considérer que tous les problèmes
viennent de l'europe
nous nous croyons en la construction
européenne et nous croyons en l'utilité
de la construction européenne pour
l'écologie car si on considère que le
meilleur slogan pour l'union européenne
c'est l'union fait la force
et bien la force d'une politique
écologique elle est évidemment beaucoup
plus importante quand on l'a fait pour
500 millions d'habitants que si on la
faisait tout seul dans notre coin
concernant les ambitions françaises je
pense que vous avez mal suivi le dernier
conseil européen car c'est la france qui
avec une coalition de huit pays avec le
président de la république qui a porté
une motion pour que la position de
l'union européenne dans les négociations
internationales
ce soit justement la neutralité carbone
qui est le référentiel de l'accord de
paris et au départ vous le savez
peut-être et bien l'allemagne n'avait
pas accepté de signer cette motion est
maintenant elle a accepté de suivre la
france sur cette position et nous allons
continuer à rassembler les pays
européens pour une raison simple
monsieur le sénateur c'est que au niveau
européen
il y à des batailles à mener il faut les
mener
et on peut les gagner nous l'avons fait
par exemple sur les émissions de co2 des
voitures et je ne sais pas si vous avez
suivi cela au mois d'octobre et de
novembre dernier
et bien c'est pareil on m'avait dit
avant que j'aille mener cette
négociation nom de la france vous savez
en matière de constructeur automobile
c'est toujours l'allemagne qui gagne
enfin et bien en l'occurrence c'est la
position française sur laquelle s'est
rassemblé l'ensemble des pays de l'union
européenne
et aujourd'hui nous avons obtenu un
objectif très concret qui va faire que
les industriels de l'automobile vont
devoir proposer à tous les européens
des voitures qui consomment moins et qui
polluent moins monsieur mari merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre l'europe mérite mieux qu'un
troisième tour de l'élection
présidentielle vous vous présentez comme
un rempart contre l'extrême droite
en fait vous avez organisé un rencard
avec madame le pen vous kidnappé le
débat européen
l'europe doit tourner la page du
libéralisme et changer de cap pour une
europe véritablement écologique et
sociale avec une nouvelle majorité de
gauche au parlement européen
[Applaudissements]
la parole est notre collègue jean pierre
decool pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à madame la garde
des sceaux elle concerne le projet
convenu d'appeler unités pour détenus
violents
cette structure nouvelle est destiné à
accueillir des détenus dont le seul
langage et la violence verbale et
physique ce qui rend bien entendu la
cohabitation avec les autres détenus et
a fortiori avec le personnel
pénitentiaire très difficile voire
impossible compte tenu de l'augmentation
significative des agressions de la
difficulté à gérer cette violence une
réflexion s'est engagée pour tenter de
trouver des solutions nouvelles
d'où ce concept d'unité pour des plus
violents dont la vocation est de
sociabiliser des individus pour lesquels
la prise en charge classique n'est pas
adapté il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre des
conditions d possible intégration en
détention classique
une première unité a été ouverte dans la
prison de sequedin dans le nord une
première en france
pourquoi ce choix l'établissement
nordiste dispose d'une expérience forte
en matière de prise en charge
psychologique et donc d'un vrai savoir
faire
ce qui a permis d'accélérer le
dispositif
cette unité que j'ai eu l'occasion de
visiter la semaine dernière permet
d'accueillir une dizaine de ces détenus
violents dans des cellules individuelles
pour un suivi très personnalisé par des
psychologues des conseillers
pénitentiaires les surveillants sans
entrer dans le détail le séjour ne doit
pas dépasser 2 fois en discutant
longuement avec les acteurs du projet
j'ai ressenti une véritable motivation
il convictions fortes sur l'opportunité
de ce concept qu'il convient
d'encourager certes il faudra du recul
pour apprécier l'efficacité de ce
dispositif récent quelles seront donc
vos orientations et évoqué le
développement des initiatives identiques
à strasbourg marseille
prendrez-vous le temps d'évaluer
l'expérimentation de ses copains pour
démarrer les autres projets où ces
derniers démarre ont-ils rapidement dans
la foulée si tel était le cas
quel serait le coût de cette opération
et quels moyens entendez vous mobiliser
je vous remercie
tarlet pour vous répondre car madame le
garde des sceaux mise d'injustice madame
belloubet merci monsieur le président
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs le
sénateur monsieur le sénateur votre
question a été rédigée de telle sorte
qu'elle montre l'intérêt de cette
structure que vous avez bien voulu
souligner nous avons en effet décidé
d'ouvrir à lille sequedin cette année d
une unité pour détenus violents
cette unité s'inscrit dans un cadre plus
général que j'ai eu l'occasion
d'exprimer devant vous il s'agit de
construire dans nos prisons à la fois
des parcours d'individualisation qu'ils
soient qui permettent de prendre les
détenus dans les différentes étapes de
leur parcours de peine est également un
régime différencié de prise en charge
des détenus qui est construit en
fonction de leur degré de dangerosité
pour les détenus les plus violents ces
unités dont vous avez souligné l'intérêt
nous permettent de prendre en charge une
dizaine de détenus avec un encadrement
soutenu et adapté avec un régime de
détention particulier l'idée c'est
évidemment d'aller faire un
désengagement du processus de violence
pour ensuite pour voir les réintégrer en
détention ordinaire ou bien s'il y a un
échec dans un lieu de détention adapté
nous avons ouvert nous à louvain ouvrir
pardon d'ici la fin du mois de juin
monsieur le sénateur quatre quartiers
pour détenu violent de ce type là l'un
aux baumettes l'autre à strasbourg et
enfin à rennes nous en ouvrirons 6
supplémentaires d'ici la fin de l'année
le coût est de 1 million 5 d'euros il
est prévu sur le budget 2010 9 et il est
assuré grâce à loi de programmation pour
la justice que vous avez bien voulu
adopter
je soulignerai pour terminer car c'est
évidemment essentiel que les personnels
pénitentiaires qu'il s'agisse des
surveillants des psychologues sont
spécialement formés pour prendre en
charge ces détenus c'est évidemment
important
par ailleurs un comité d'évaluation et
de suivi sera mis en place pour évaluer
l'impact de ces
de ces procédures de ces régimes adaptés
et pour en mesurer la pertinence si
l'impact est positif nous continuerons à
déployer ses quartiers pour détenus
violents
merci la parole est maintenant président
christian cambon pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères mardi aux invalides
autour du président de la république la
france
bouleversée a rendu un hommage solennel
à cédric de pierre pons et alain berton
de celle au ses héros du commandant
hubert qui avec leurs camarades ont
sauvé des otages touristes inconscients
des dangers qu'il courait dans cette
région du nord bénin
ces soldats ont accompli un exploit ils
l'ont payé de leur vie
mais ils ont aussi montré ainsi que la
france n'abandonne jamais ses enfants
nous ne les oublierons pas et à cet
instant nous pensons à leurs familles à
leurs camarades de combat et à ses
milliers de soldats qui pour notre
compte combattent au sahel pour la
sécurité de l'europe toute entière
laissons si vous le voulez bien de côté
les polémiques sur les conditions
d'accueil de ces touristes à l'aéroport
de villacoublay où la couleur des cartes
au quai d'orsay
chacun a son idée sur ce sujet et notre
hémicycle n'est pas le lieu des
polémiques
en revanche c'est dans notre hémicycle
ici même que nous votons les
prolongations de missions de ces soldats
que nous votons les crédits d'équipement
nécessaires à l'accomplissement de ses
missions dangereuses et donc nous aussi
nous partageons quelque part la
responsabilité de ce qui leur arrive et
nous devons être économe de leur vie
économe de leur souffrance d'alors
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple puisque des touristes
irresponsable continueront sûrement à
chercher laventure dans ces contrats
dangereuse n'est-il pas temps d'exiger
de ces pays acp
ce qu une politique plus sévère d'octroi
des visas touristiques pour ces zones
infestées par le terrorisme et plus
largement
pouvez-vous nous assurer que tout va
être fait pour que nos soldats qui
paient déjà un très lourd tribut à la
lutte contre le djihadisme n'est pas en
plus à payer de leur vie les
responsabilités de ces aventuriers
inconscient en mal d'émotions fortes
le beau merci pour vos répondre la
parole est
le secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'europe des affaires étrangères
monsieur jean-baptiste lemoyne monsieur
le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président quand bon
naturellement nous nous joignons à
l'hommage poignant que vous avez rendu
au maître de pierrepont et ce fut un
moment de communion très fort la nation
toute entière était réunie et au delà
pour avoir reçu le témoignage de nombre
de nos partenaires européens et
africains
très clairement c'est un message très
fort qui était lancée vis-à-vis de
toutes celles et tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient s'en prendre à nos
compatriotes qu'ils soient français
établis hors de france et nous le savons
ils sont plusieurs millions notamment
établi sur le continent africain
qu'ils soient touristes est dans un
monde où nous voyons la multiplication
des foyers de crise de tension et bien
cela appelle très clairement une
vigilance accrue vigilance accrue de la
part de c est ceux qui souhaitent se
rendre à l'étranger en consultant
systématiquement effectivement ses
conseils aux voyageurs et je rends
hommage au centre de crise et de soutien
du quai d'orsay qui veille à la
meilleure information possible en lien
naturellement avec les opérateurs de
voyages cela veut dire aussi inciter nos
compatriotes qui se rendent à l'étranger
à s'inscrire sur la plateforme
ariane et puis s'appelle une
responsabilité accrue individuel
naturellement les ex-otages ont
d'ailleurs reconnu qu'il aurait
peut-être dû suivre plus scrupuleusement
un certain nombre de recommandations est
par ailleurs une responsabilité des
opérateurs notamment des plateformes en
ligne et je les réunis ray dans les
prochains jours s'agissant des mesures
de visa vous le savez ce sont des
mesures qui relèvent de la souveraineté
de chacun des états mais il est très
clair que dans les défis que nous avons
à relever ensemble entre européens entre
africains nous devons avoir un dialogue
danse et y compris sur ces sujets pour
qu'aucun risque ne soient courues de
façon supplémentaire par des femmes et
des hommes qui portant l'uniforme ont
déjà fort à faire à traquer les
djihadistes
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
olivier cigolotti pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président la question
trop longue jeu celle du président
christian cambon en effet cédric de
pierrepont et alain berton de chez nous
sont allés au bout de leur mission
jusqu'au sacrifice de leur vie ils ont
permis la libération de quatre otages
donc deux de nos compatriotes notre
groupe s'incline devant le courage et la
détermination de ces deux militaires
d'exception
nos pensées vont à leurs proches à leur
famille à leurs frères d'armes
cet événement tragique remet au coeur de
l'actualité la situation politique de
l'afrique de l'ouest
l'heure n'est pas à la polémique cela a
été dit mais plutôt de questionnement
sur les éléments liés à la sécurité
dans cette bande sahélo saharienne dont
la superficie je le rappelle était
équivalente à celle de l'europe tout
entière en questionnement tout d'abord
sur la force conjointe du g5 sel
cette dernière n'est actuellement pas en
mesure d'assurer totalement sa mission à
savoir la sécurité dans la zone des
trois frontières du tchad du mali du
niger et le sera t elle un jour compte
tenu des difficultés qu'elles
rencontrent
il est évident que les groupes armés
terroristes ont des connexions entre eux
et se joue de la stratégie du g5 sahel
mon deuxième questionnement porte sur
l'action de la france et son engagement
dans cette région du monde
nos forces armées font au quotidien sur
ces territoires hostiles un travail
remarquable mais la france semble bien
seul ou presque et dessertes
efficacement par nos alliés historiques
que sont nos amis britanniques et
américains en traits de développement et
présence militaire
combien de temps allons-nous continuer à
l'it est pratiquement seule avec force
et détermination contre la barbarie et
le fanatisme
monsieur le ministre la lutte contre le
terrorisme est un enjeu international
quand aurons nous enfin compter sur un
véritable engagement européen au sel
pour vous répondre la parole et aux
secrétaires d'état produits de l'europe
des affaires étrangères monsieur le
ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs cigolotti mardi alors
même que la nation était rassemblée
autour de nos deux héros à bruxelles
étaient réunis les ministres des
affaires étrangères les ministres de la
défense européens est également membres
du g5 sel ce fut l'occasion d'un hommage
également rendu à nos héros dans cette
enceinte et cela montre si cette réunion
est bien la prise de conscience qui
existent au niveau européen sur
l'importance d'unir nos forces et nos
actions afin d'apporter des réponses
dans le long terme à cette zone
sahélienne effectivement déstabilisé par
est bien de nombreux actes terroristes
les la nuit dernière a hélas apporter
encore une confirmation avec l'attak
contre plusieurs dizaines de soldats
nigériens face à cela la réponse allait
multidimensionnelle elle est sécuritaire
vous l'avez rappelé avec la montée en
puissance de la force conjointe g5 sahel
les européens ont d'ailleurs mis 100
millions d'euros pour équiper pour
participer à une meilleure formation des
troupes près de 4000 hommes des cinq
pays est aujourd'hui cette force très
clairement monte en puissance avec des
sorties très régulière sur le terrain la
réponse elle est au delà de l'aspect
sécuritaire également en matière de
développement et c'est pourquoi nous
avons tenu à mettre en place l'alliance
elle qui à l'initiative du président de
la république à l'initiative d'angela
merkel est bien mais ensemble tous les
bailleurs tous les donneurs pour avoir
des procédures plus rapides et avoir un
impact sur le terrain en matière
d'éducation en matière d'accès à
l'emploi
parce que c'est ça qui empêchera des
jeunes de basculer dans le radicalisme
et puis la réponse allait également
politique et
cela a été dit mardi à bruxelles dans la
région du nord au mali dans la région du
centre au mali l'impératif dialogue qui
doit être noué pour enfin apporter des
réponses pérennes que cigolotti la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
patricia sillinger pour le groupe de la
république est en marche
vous avez la parole
madame la secrétaire d'état aujourd'hui
même se tient le duo des inerties
initiative qui permet à une personne en
situation de handicap d'être accueillis
par un professionnel au sein d'une
entreprise d'une collectivité ou d'une
association lancée par un esat du lot et
garonne est soutenu par votre action
résolue cet événement est désormais
d'ampleur nationale et ce sont plus de
12000 duo qui se sont constitués pour
cette quatrième édition le temps de
cette journée
employeurs et personnes handicapées vont
se rencontrer échanger et travailler
ensemble croiser leur expérience et leur
vécu
l'objectif est de développer les
opportunités d'insertion professionnelle
en surmontant les préjugés qui fait non
freine l'emploi des personnes
handicapées
la tâche est immense comme nous le
rappelle la citation d'albert einstein
reprises sur la plateforme diodel il est
plus facile de désintégrer un atom que
qu'un préjugé
si nous devons nous féliciter de la
mobilisation grandissante autour de cet
événement ce changement de regard doit
absolument s'accompagner de mobilisation
de tous pour les politiques
particulièrement volontariste en france
2,7 millions de personnes sont en
situation de handicap est en âge de
travailler
le taux de chômage des travailleurs
handicapés et de 19% et trois quarts des
demandeurs d'emploi handicapés ont un
niveau de qualification inférieur au bac
aussi madame la ministre pourriez vous
nous détailler l'action du gouvernement
en matière d'incitation de l'emploi à
l'emploi direccte de formations
professionnelles d'accès à l'emploi et
de sécurisation des parcours
professionnels pour les personnes en
situation de handicap
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état chargé
des personnes handicapées vous avez la
parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
tout d'abord permettez moi de vous
remercier monsieur le président pour cet
échange que nous avons eues avec nos
d'audio ici présents pour échanger et
entendre la parole des personnes car
c'est ce qui nous anime dans notre
politique publique la participation des
personnes en situation de handicap leur
donner la parole montrer leurs
compétences leur envie de travailler au
milieu des autres
alors oui cette édition est un succès 25
mille personnes aujourd'hui qu'ils vont
travailler ensemble donner l'opportunité
de pouvoir découvrir des nouveaux
métiers mais maintenant il faut passer
en effet la vitesse supérieure et c'est
tout l'enjeu de notre politique publique
que je porte avec muriel pénicaud et
olivier du soft simplifiée simplifier la
vie des entreprises
aujourd'hui la complexité n'est plus une
excuse car nous avons simplifié et
automatisé les déclarations au sein des
déclaration sociale nominative droit
commun mais efficacité et lisibilité
nous offrons des prestations de services
aux entreprises pour pouvoir les
accompagner
accompagner les personnes en situation
de handicap nous allons développer
jusqu'à 50000 personnes emploi
accompagnent et donc nous généralisons
vraiment ce dispositif nous rapprochons
pour l'emploi un cap emploi pour
qu'enfin les personnes n'est plus une
errance dans leur parcours d'aller
frapper à toutes les portes différentes
donc nous nous mettons en ordre de
marche aussi de créer une plateforme de
ressources numériques que j'ai confiée à
la caisse des dépôts et la scène et ça
pour avoir cette première brique
employés handicap pour simplifier et les
rendre lisibles et pour les personnes et
pour les associations et pour les
entreprises privées ou publiques qui
souhaitent vraiment modéliser la
réussite accompagne et à l'emploi mais
accompagnés et maintenir dans l'emploi
c'est tout l'enjeu d'éviter la
désinsertion professionnelle et de
travailler sur une reconversion
professionnelle pour qu'enfin toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap et
leur place un emploi mais surtout et
c'est l'enjeu de demain puissent rester
au sein de l'emploi donc une politique
tout simplement qui s'appuie sur la
volonté des personnes
ce travail au milieu des autres notre
société s'enrichit de la différence
ainsi et c'est comme ça que tout le
gouvernement travaille pour cette
politique handicap qui est la priorité
du quinquennat
merci
un homme soulagé la parole était
maintenant notre collègue françoise
laborde pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur
les scandales sanitaires récurrents
place la question du bien manger
au coeur des enjeux de santé publique un
pan du sujet n'est jamais évoquée
l'articulation entre ordre public et
continuité alimentaire par le passé
notre modèle agricole reposait sur le
foncier nourricier et sur un aménagement
du territoire local multifonctionnel la
sécurité alimentaire était une
préoccupation des élus aujourd'hui
production et consommation ne sont plus
terreau territorialisées même les zones
rurales sont alimentairement vulnérables
perfusé par le ballet des camions de la
grande distribution
à l'heure des cyber attaques du
dérèglement climatique et du terrorisme
production et approvisionnements
alimentaires ne sont pas analysés comme
risques stratégiques
des signes on nous alertent pourtant la
moindre annonce de blocages routiers
vides les magasins avant toute pénurie
provoquant même des émeutes comme il y à
peu en outre mer en cas de force majeure
le déficit en capacités de subvenir
localement a donné à l'un de nos besoins
primaires celui de se nourrir est
flagrant les populations ne sont pas
préparés assurer un niveau minimum de
sécurité d'approvisionnement alimentaire
est un devoir pour les autorités qui
devrait pouvoir garantir une chaîne
résiliente allant du foncier agricole
nourricier jusqu'au consommateur
cela doit nous interroger sur la
souveraineté et la sécurité nationales
articulé autour des biens communs alors
que les pouvoirs publics perdent peu à
peu la main sur les infrastructures
d'intérêt vital comme les aéroports
le foncier agricole ou la gestion de
l'eau il est urgent de sont préoccupés
pouvez vous nous préciser monsieur le
ministre si cette question fait l'objet
d'une réflexion dans votre ministère au
secrétariat général
de la défense et de la sécurité
nationale je vous remercie vous répandre
la parole et à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur questionnaire vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs c'est un terreau madame la
sénatrice laborde
vous m'interrogez sur la stratégie qui
serait mise en cause pour garantir la
sécurité alimentaire en cas de troubles
graves à l'ordre public
c'est une question dans la probabilité
est faible mais dont le risque est
majeur
il est essentiel et votre question
effectivement nécessite que nous
puissions y répondre permettez moi
d'évoquer ce que nous faisons en matière
de gestion de troubles graves mais liées
à des catastrophes naturelles et c'est
ce modèle là qui évidemment nous devons
mettre en oeuvre et que nous pouvons
mettre en oeuvre un cadre en cas de
gestion grave à l'ordre public lors des
catastrophes naturelles vous le savez
mais je vous le rappelle la chaîne
d'approvisionnement est prise en compte
immédiatement dans le cadre des plans
dits orsec que chacun ici connaît les
préfets agissent dans ce cadre là sous
le pilotage du sgdsn que vous avez
évoquées pour garantir évidemment la
bonne à privations le borgne
approvisionnement il ya un plan d'action
spécifique et mises en oeuvre
immédiatement pour l'accès à l'eau
potable pour l'alimentation pour
l'énergie électrique les communications
électroniques le gaz et des
hydrocarbures et je peux vous indiquer
que de façon régulière
il y à des mises en contact avec les
différents opérateurs pour justement
garantir cela c'est à dire ce plan
d'urgence que nous avions mis en place
aux antilles lors du passage de
l'ouragan wilma quatre millions de
litres d'eau 375 tonnes de denrées
avaient été distribués en urgence pour
subvenir aux besoins de la population et
enquêtes en détresse et un travail
immédiat avait été lancée et très
intense avec les opérateurs dont orange
et edf mais aussi avec l'aide de l'armée
par exemple pour garantir l'alimentation
et je pense à l'eau potable et donc
c'est ce modèle là que nous pouvons
mettre en oeuvre en cas de troubles
importants à l'ordre public et
naturellement c'est dans ce cadre là que
nous devons prendre en compte aussi la
sécurité alimentaire et je conclus en
vous disant qu' il peut aussi
arrivé que dans le cadre des troubles en
paix que ce soient les points
d'approvisionnement qui soit
particulièrement visés et là encore je
crois que nos forces de sécurité
intérieure ont fait la démonstration de
leur capacité à savoir libérer ces
points quand cela était nécessaire sans
pour autant provoquer de tensions
extrêmement grave je remercie la parole
et à notre collègue bernard jomier pour
le groupe socialiste et républicain
la parole dit dans mes dames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues sans médecins ont récemment
appelé à ne pas renseigner le fichier
civique de bernard debré à xavier
emmanuelli d'andré grimaldi à philippe
de normandie où irène kahn-bensaude et
certains sur les bancs de notre
assemblée
nos parcours nos opinions sont très
différents mais nous avons en commun de
ne pas accepter jamais que des
informations médicales et nominative
soient transmises à des personnes qui ne
concourent pas directement aux soins il
s'agit là d'une violation grave du
secret professionnel
le fichier civique est une procédure
exceptionnelle déclenché en cas d'actes
dac fut exceptionnelle de victimes
il a été détourné de son objet à
l'occasion du mouvement dit des gilet
jaune du seul fait de leur participation
à ce mouvement des personnes ont vu des
informations médicales et nominative
collectées et transmises l'ap-hp après
des déclarations successives a fini par
admettre la réalité des faits les
signataires ont interpellé le parlement
alors madame la ministre
allez-vous diligenter une enquête
indépendante sur ces faits allez vous
cesser et désavoué cette collecte
d'informations qui ne respectent pas les
conditions posées par la cnil à la mise
en oeuvre de civic je remercie pour vous
répondre la parole
quand la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
d'un cristal du golf vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur bernard jomier le système
d'information civique aide les hôpitaux
les établissements de santé à répondre à
une entrée à une arrivée exceptionnelle
de blessés lors d'un événement
particulier
il est activé lorsqu'un événement
susceptible de générer beaucoup de
blessés est désactivé quand l'événement
en question prend fin à titre d'exemple
le système civique a été activé lors
d'explosions
il ya une fuite de gaz 9e arrondissement
de paris ou lors des inondations dans
l'aude mais permettez-moi de revenir
quelques années en arrière en 2015
chacun s'en souviendra malheureusement
par des attentats les vagues les
victimes ont été réparties dans
l'urgence entre les établissements
avaient des difficultés à savoir ensuite
où chacune se trouvait et une faiblesse
des autorités à renseigner les familles
à avoir un bilan précis à anticiper la
surcharge des services d'urgence le
système civique a donc été créé à la
suite de ce constat avec l'objectif
laissez-moi terminé je vais y venir avec
l'objectif lors de chaque événement
grave d'organiser le plus vite et le
mieux possible la prise en charge des
blessés et de l'accompagnement de leurs
proches
l'utilisation du système civique est
utile soignants aux hôpitaux aux ars en
cas de situation sanitaire exceptionnel
néanmoins la ministre des solidarités de
la santé agnès buzyn l'a rappelé et
répété et je la cite jamais nous
n'accepterons que l'on demande soignants
de ficher des jd jaune qu'il soigne
jamais d'ailleurs il n'accepterait il ya
eu un malentendu pouvoir repérer les
victimes de blessures en marge de
manifestations pour adapter le système
de santé ne veut pas dire ficher des
gilet jaune lors des manifestations ont
été activés civis toutes les personnes
en lien avec les manifestations forces
de l'ordre un journaliste passant
manifestants ont pu potentiellement être
rentré dans civique sans distinction
nous avons demandé à la direction
compétente du ministère de la santé à
l'ap-hp et aux aux ars de faire acte de
transparence notamment sur le
fonctionnement de civic c'est
l'inspection commune de la rs
ile-de-france et de l'ap-hp est
diligentée afin d'évaluer ses eu des
dysfonctionnements et s'assurer que ce
fichier sera désormais strictement
constituée d'informations juillet madame
la ministre
on ne demande pas à ceux qui sont
susceptibles d'avoir commis l'infraction
de mener l enquête
c'est un principe étonnant quand même en
termes juridiques
par ailleurs le fichier civique a
clairement été dévoyé l'ordre de mettre
des médecins a saisi la cnil mais
malheureusement vous ne respectez pas
l'avis de la cnil comme sur
l'utilisation d'un autre fichier santé
ops site web qui a été croisé avec un
fichier du ministère l'intérieur
madame la ministre les fondements de
notre éthique du soin ne sont pas un
mercato
la parole est à notre collègue hugues
schori pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole vous chers collègues
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
solidarités de la santé madame la
ministre vous le savez l'une des
préoccupations majeures des français
concerne l'accès aux soins et plus
spécifiquement la possibilité de trouver
un médecin à proximité de leur lieu de
vie il existe sur le territoire national
des régions entières où cette difficulté
d'accès posent un grave est réel
problème de santé publique
la région centre val de loire le
département du loiret sont parmi les
plus défavorisés en nombre de médecins
par habitant
un rendez vous chez un cardiologue c'est
un an
idem pour un ophtalmo il faut six mois
pour rencontrer un allergologue ou ainsi
un gynéco et pour un nouvel arrivant
dans l'orléanais il est quasiment
impossible de trouver un généraliste la
région le département les communes se
sont mobilisés ensemble depuis longtemps
avec constance et ténacité pour proposer
des solutions
en vain car si les structures existent
encore faut-il trouver les praticiens
pour les remplir
ce constat peut être effectuée dans de
très nombreux autres départements et
d'ailleurs
outre mes collègues du loiret rémy
pointereau sénateur du cher s'associer à
des questions qu'il souhaitait lui-même
posé
madame la ministre beaucoup d'autres
nous ont été consternés par l'annoncé du
chiffre du numerus clausus du paces pour
la rentrée prochaine avec une vision
globale on peut se féliciter de son
évolution brut puisqu'il augmente de 13
5%
pas mieux pour les grands centres
urbains tels que paris lyon aix
marseille et quelques autres où le
nombre d'admissibles progresse
sensiblement mais qu'en est il des
facultés siège de territoires plus
ruraux tels que caen clermont ferrand
dijon poitiers reims et tours notamment
le statu quo au total on constate pour
cette dernière année d'existence du
numerus clausus une stagnation
inquiétante pour 17 des 30 faculté de
médecine de métropole ce qui nous
scandalise c'est l'absence de prise en
compte du problème dramatique de
désertification médicale dans la
définition du nombre d'étudiants admis à
signer des études de médecine
cela signifie que les déshérités
d'aujourd'hui le seront davantage encore
demain qu'on fait les habitants de ces
régions pourraient être privés un votre
droit etc essentielle être correctement
soigné
madame la ministre quels sont les
critères qui ont conduit à
l'augmentation des effectifs de
certaines facultés et à la stagnation
d'autres sur merci vous répondre par
omettre la ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche et l'innovation
mon abidal vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur saurai la lutte
contre
la désertification médicale est au coeur
du plan
ma santé de mes 22 et du projet de loi
de santé dont l'examen vient de
commencer au sénat en commission
notre objectif c'est effectivement de
prendre à bras le corps ce problème et
de le prendre de façon globale avec des
réponses qui pourront être apportées à
court terme et des réponses qui seront
plus longues à prendre leurs effets
puisque comme vous le savez la formation
d'un médecin 7 entre 9 et 15 ans quelles
sont les propositions qui seront faites
dans le cadre de ce projet doit sentais
bien c'est de permettre à des jeunes de
démarrer leurs études médicales dans
tous les territoires et non plus
seulement dans les métropoles dans
lesquels se trouvent des chu et au delà
leur permettent aussi d'avoir accès à
des stages de troisième cycle là encore
dans l'ensemble des territoires et de ce
point de vue là c'est une réponse
structurelle de long terme sur les
réponses de court terme ce sont la
création les assistants médicaux
le recrutement des 400 médecins
généralistes et la façon dont nous
allons organiser le système de santé
réorganiser ce système au plus proche
des territoires
vous m'interrogez spécifiquement sur la
façon dont le numerus clausus a été fixé
pour la rentrée 2010 9 il se trouve que
nous sommes dans l'application de la loi
actuelle et non pas dans l'application
de la future loi et les augmentations
vous avez pu constater tiennent au fait
qu' un certain nombre d'établissements à
titre expérimental et bien sont déjà
dans les nouvelles formes de paces qui
permettront dès la rentrée de mes 20 à
l'ensemble des territoires de bénéficier
d'une augmentation leur numerus clausus
jour merci merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
madame nathalie goulet
oui merci monsieur le président pour un
groupe de l'union centriste
merci ma question s'adresse à monsieur
ministre de l'intérieur non content
d'être interdit de séjour en france en
grande-bretagne aux etats-unis dans de
nombreux pays musulmans dont les émirats
arabes unis recherché par interpol
finances est hébergé par le kata yusuf
al qaradawi leader des frères musulmans
a lancé depuis dublin une application
qui s'appelle euros fatwa ap
brûlot anti sémite déroulant sa haine à
longueur de page
suite à une intervention conjointe de
collègues britanniques et de la
fondation des musulmans contre
l'antisémitisme nous avons pu obtenir sa
suppression par google le 11 mai dernier
mais l'application est toujours en place
sur apple or des disciples et admirateur
de qaradawi diffuse sa pensée en france
en ce moment même un dîner caritatif
annoncé comme déductibles d'impôt
devrait avoir lieu le 25 mai prochain à
saint-denis
il a été précédé par une tournée de
douze conférences et collecte de fonds
dont je tiens les documents avec
disposition au profit écoutez bien de
l'institut de formation des oulémas
mauritaniens
or l'institut proche des frères
musulmans a été fermé par les autorités
mauritaniennes
car il enseignait un islam radical en
vidéo le shakedown connu pour prêcher
l'islam radical anti sémite reprochant
notamment aux musulmans d'avoir exprimé
leur tristesse lors de l' incendie de
notre dame
monsieur le ministre comment expliquez
vous que nous autorisions ce type de
manifestations potentiellement
dangereuse pour l'ordre public qui
constitue un soutien évident à une
activité prohibée en mauritanie via des
collectes de fonds la mauritanie chef de
file du g5 sahel que nous soutenons avec
nos troupes dans cette région pouvait
vous interdire cette manifestation et
interdire cette application
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur me d'intérieur me tue castanet
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs ces internats dames la
sénatrice goulet m'interroger sur ce
dîner caritatif entre guillemets
organisée par les frères musulmans
effectivement annoncé comme au bénéfice
de l'institut de formation des oulémas
mauritaniens
j'ai eu connaissance ce dîner j'en ai
informé j'ai comment dire demandé
quelques renseignements attentif sur
l'organisation de ce dîner je peux vous
indiquer que cette manifestation a été
annulée et qu'elle n'aura pas lieu
je voudrais madame la sénatrice vous
dire que il ne nous appartient pas
d'autoriser pour reprendre vos mots la
tenue d'un dîner caritatif ou autres
quelle qu'en soit l'objet
par contre il nous appartient d'être
vigilants et de faire en sorte que si
nous considérons et je suis prêt à
considérer avec vous compte itunes votre
question qu'il y a un trouble manifeste
à l'ordre public nous devons intervenir
et c'est ce que nous faisons de façon
systématique
la deuxième question que vous posez et
celles évoquées effectivement dans cette
affiche que j'ai vu comme vous selon
lequel la participation ou les dons
seraient déductibles fiscalement là
encore vous préciser que ce contrôle est
fait a posteriori et qu'évidemment
notamment sur des financements liés à
l'étranger il ya un soin tout
particulier de l'administration fiscale
pour refuser que ce genre de financement
puisse bénéficier d'une déduction
fiscale et nous devons contrôler cela
avec une grande attention
et quand il y as fraude il y a même tout
un dispositif d'amandes et de suspension
des avantages fiscaux qui peut être
mobilisés et qui doit être mobilisée sur
ce sujet jouer madame la sénatrice dans
les quelques secondes qui me restent
vous dire combien nous portons une
attention toute particulière à la
diffusion de ce genre d'idées qui menace
l'ordre public et qu'évidemment et je
crois surtout les bons ici nous
condamnons le plus fermement je vous ai
indiqué que depuis 2018
nous avons engagé au ministère de
l'intérieur la fermeture de 27 lieux de
culte en france actuellement 20 sont
encore fermées dans le cadre de ces
procédures je pense que c'est un chiffre
qui n'a jamais été atteint
dans le même esprit sous l'autorité et
en lien avec le milieu du casse sociale
quatre écoles hors contrat huit
établissements culturels ou associatifs
ont été fermés
89 débits de boisson l'ont été aussi
dans le cadre des dispositifs de la loi
sylt l'eau à sylt qui nous permet
effectivement d'avoir la proche la plus
large possible entente que ce genre de
lieux ne puisse pas diffuser les idées
malsaines qu'il peut porter boulet oui
monsieur le ministre
ma police est aussi papa aussi bien fait
que la vôtre mais presque le dîner a été
déplacé au 25
il a toujours lieu à saint denis la
deuxième chose c'est qu'on a eu la
déclaration
la déclaration de christophe et je vous
demande monsieur le ministre de faire de
faire application de cette déclaration
avec cette application euros fatwa je
tiens l'ensemble des documents à votre
disposition c'est un brûlot antisémites
absolument inacceptable la parole est à
notre collègue marie christine chauvin
pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation monsieur le ministre la
commission européenne paraît déterminé à
conclure au plus vite un accord
commercial avec le mercosur
c'est à dire le brésil l'argentine
l'uruguay et le paraguay
le ministre brésilien du commerce luc
aphérèse vient d'ailleurs de déclarer
qu'un accord n'a jamais été aussi proche
en l'état des négociations cet accord
d'une part conduirait à ce que le
citoyen français consomment plus de
viande ne correspond pas ne
correspondant pas à nos normes
environnementales et sanitaires que nous
imposons à nous mêmes est d'autre part
mettrait nos agriculteurs dans une
situation de concurrence parfaitement
déloyal
la commission fait des choix de plus en
plus singulier dans le monde on peut
légitimement se demander s'il est
raisonnable d'envisager de brader notre
souveraineté alimentaire
n'y at il pas contradiction à faire de
la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique une priorité est envisagée en
même temps d'importer des volumes de
viande ne répondant à aucune demande
alors que la sagesse et la cohérence
devrait nous amener à choisir une autre
voie
monsieur le ministre allez vous défendre
les intérêts des éleveurs
est des consommateurs le gouvernement
va-t-il ans terry mais toutes les
concessions destiné à ouvrir les
frontières européennes aux produits sud
américains s'en tenir compte notamment
de l'exigence environnementale
monsieur le ministre l'adoption du
mercosur concernent des domaines qui
nécessitent l'unanimité des états au
conseil européen je me permets de vous
demander monsieur le ministre
quelle sera la position du gouvernement
français la parole est à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture de
l'alimentation reçu didier guillot merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
vous l'avez bien évoquer la commission
relance des discussions pour un accord
avec le mercosur est votre question
permet de préciser à nouveau comme je lé
fais la semaine dernière à la tribune du
sénat lors de la discussion sur la ppr
eux sur la pac la position claire ferme
et net de la france le président de la
république s'est entretenu samedi
dernier avec les présidents juncker j'ai
moi même travaillé de longues heures
avec le commissaire hogan
la position de la france est claire la
france est opposée à la signature de
l'accord du mercosur voulue par la
commission actuelle parce que cet accord
ne correspond pas à aux standards que
veulent la france cet accord ne la
france le pet favorable à cet accord au
détriment de notre agriculture
la france est opposée à cet accord parce
qu'il se fera au détriment de nos
standards sanitaires la france est
opposée à cet accord parce qu'il se fera
au détriment nos standards alimentaire
et enfin la france est opposée cet
accord parce qu'il sera se fera au
détriment de l'accord de paris et de nos
critères environnementaux
ça ne peut pas être plus clair il y a
des accords internationaux qui se font
la commission et la majorité actuelle de
la commission négocier avec le mercosur
et voudrait faire entériner cet accord
la france n'y est pas favorable
et donc nous avons exprimé notre
position est en l'état actuel des choses
la france votera contre si la question
se pose mais avant qu'elle tenait cette
question de se posent les discussions
diplomatiques les discussions politiques
doivent continuer
il faut que la commission infléchi sa
position l'accord du mercosur ne peut
pas se faire au détriment des
agriculteurs de la culture française je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le ministre
j'espère vraiment que les paroles que
vous avez prononcé ici seront prononcées
d'une avec autant de fermeté d'honneur
de la commission européenne parce que on
ne peut pas concevoir demander toujours
plus d'efforts et imposer toujours plus
de normes à nos agriculteurs et en même
temps favoriser le contraire avec les
produits d'importation
ce n'est pas cohérent ce n'est pas
acceptable monsieur le ministre c'est
son de sacrifier nos agriculteurs nos
éleveurs et ses sons de trompe et nos
consommateurs
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue olivier paccaud pour le groupe
l'est républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci ma question s'adresse à
monsieur mise de l'intérieur plus de
proximité réclament les français faire
vite et faire mieux déclame le premier
ministre telle est une des équations
résoudre par le gouvernement pour
retrouver crédibilité et efficacité
or un seul exemple la délivrance des
titres de transport des titres
d'identité pardon démontre que notre
état malheureusement efface la proximité
fait lentement et fait pire
jadis est pas si loin chaque citoyen
pouvait effectuer des démarches dans sa
mairie à mary vous savez le dernier
service de proximité de très nombreuses
communes là où bat le coeur de notre
démocratie
désormais cette démarche ne peut se
faire que dans les mairies équipées
d'une station d'enregistrement dans
l'oise sur 679 communes seules 27 ans
sont équipés soit moins de 4% faut
surtout pas être pressé car les délais
d'attentes peuvent dépasser les 3 mois
non pas pour obtenir ses papiers mais
simplement pour déposer ses photos et
compléter son dossier
ce passage à l'ère biométrique n'aura
fait gagner ni temps ni argent ni
énergie une incontestable régression du
service public encore une fois éloigné
avec des kilomètres à parcourir de
l'essence a dépensé belle cohérence pour
un gouvernement d'honneur de
son d'écologie mais dont les paroles
sont toujours aux antipodes des actes
bien des élus locaux regrettent de ne
plus accueillir en mairie leur
population à l'occasion du
renouvellement de ses titres c'était
parfois l'unique moment de rencontre et
les administrés l'unique situation où
certains habitants se rendaient en
mairie à l'heure où le président de la
république a redécouvert la vertu de la
proximité et annonce la création de
relais cantonaux de service public
ne serait-il pas judicieux de revenir
sur cette réorganisation des délivrance
de titres d'identité qui n'a fait que
des mécontents
pour vous répondre la parole de toby
liste de l'intérieur vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs st faire monsieur le sénateur
je pense qu'il est inutile de vouloir
polémiquer mettre en cause le
gouvernement surtout que vous devez le
savoir parce que vous avez posé la
question mardi matin au socata d'état
qui vous a répondu et qui va vous faire
la même réponse certainement que celle
que je veux faire plus mon cabinet vous
a transmis un certain nombre de
documents la mise en place de ces outils
numériques ne relève pas de l'actuel
gouvernement mais vous avez raison il ya
un certain nombre de problèmes et donc
sans polémique je pense qu'il faut
aborder ces difficultés vous savez comme
moi que les cartes nationales d'identité
ont changé de format et que j'aurai des
marches sont dématérialisés pour faire
des outils biométrique et ça implique
d'avoir pour cela des consoles des bases
ddr dispositif de recueil qui soit à la
fois branché directement sur l'accès au
numérique et donc qu'ils soient câblés
et qui représente un coût moyen
d'environ 30000 euros
et c'est la raison pour laquelle les
gouvernements et plusieurs gouvernements
se sont mobilisés ont déployé partout en
france 3526 dispositif de recueil pour
faire en sorte qu'ils aient plus de
proximité ont confié la responsabilité
aux mairies avec un contrat qui est
passé avec les mairies pour qu'ils
puissent fonctionner au maximum
une des difficultés à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés et j'ai été maire et
je ne pourrai pas donner de leçon pour
le taux d' usage dans la commune
c'est que au fond il ne tourne pas à
100% et qu'il tourne pour le tour à une
moyenne inférieure à 35 % et la
difficulté c'est que du coup on a un
délai moyen de rendez-vous dans les
mairies pour
faire l'ensemble des procédures qui
peuvent être préparés dans toutes les
mairies mais qui doivent être
formalisées notamment pour la prise des
empreintes digitales dans certaines
mairies dans celle que je viens
d'évoquer dans les 3500 26 points
malheureusement nous avons des délais
moyens qui sont trop importants 22 jours
par exemple dans votre département
ce qui correspond à la moyenne nationale
que nous connaissons et 55 %
d'utilisation est ce qu un score
meilleur que celui que j'évoquais dans
votre département
j'ai fait la proposition au premier
ministre il ya quelques jours de
rajouter une centaine de dispositifs et
d'équipements pour mailler le territoire
et je regarderai avec vous si vous
voulez bien dans votre département nous
pourrions renforcer l'équipement
territoriale je vous remercie monsieur
bako merci un ancien président de la
république avait promis un choc de
simplification un autre avait demandé d'
arrêter d'emmerder les français
force est de constater qu'ils n'ont pas
été entendus pour conclure je vous
laisse méditer la devise d'une belle
commune de l'oise pierrefonds qui veut
peut bien
merci nous avons terminé que les
questions d'actualité merci monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres
prochaine question le 21 mai je vais
suspendre la séance jusqu'à 16h15 et
nous reprendrons le projet de loi pour
une école de la confiance merci la
séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement ou que vous
l'avez vu le sénateur socialiste de
paris bernard jomier a interpellé le
gouvernement sur la polémique autour de
la collecte d'informations médicales des
gilet jaune blessées lors des
manifestations une collecte dans le
fichier civique normalement utilisé pour
les victimes d'attentats le sénateur a
demandé au gouvernement une enquête
indépendante sur cette affaire qu'il
appelle du fichage gouvernementale la
secrétaire d'état
christelle du bos a répondu en réfutant
ce mot de fichage et elle assuré que
cette collecte d'informations avaient
permis d'adapter le système de santé au
traitement des blessés lors de cette
manifestation et puis elle a informé que
l' agence régionale de santé étaient en
train de mener une enquête pour faire
toute la transparence sur cette affaire
et puis il a été question des élections
européennes durant cette séance de
questions d'actualité
didier marie le sénateur socialiste a
critiqué le tournant soit disant
écologique de la politique d' emmanuel
macron et le manque d'ambition de la
france sur le climat sur la scène
internationale le ministre de la
transition écologique et solidaire
françois de rugy lui a répondu en
rappelant que la france dans les
négociations européennes avait réussi à
faire plier l'allemagne sur la
neutralité carbone et sur les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de l'industrie
automobile et puis les sénateurs sont
revenus sur la mort des deux soldats
français dans l'opération de libération
des otages
au burkina faso le président de la
commission des affaires étrangères au
sénat christian cambon a qualifié ces
otages de touristes inconscients et puis
le centriste olivier cigolotti a déploré
la solitude de la france dans le combat
contre le djihadisme en afrique voilà
delphine pour les temps forts de ces
questions d'actualité du sénat au
gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre pour vos
précisions et on va continuer à
l'analyse de cette séance avec eux mon
invité et j'aimerais mentionner bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous un sénateur et
l'air de l'essonne un bon justement sur
ces soldats tués en libérant et
otage on a entendu christian cambon ne
veux pas revenir sur la polémique
m'excusant à des imprudences et de
touristes français je crois d'abord que
christian cambon a été très digne dans
son intervention il a rappelé qu'on ne
n'étais pas là dans l'hémicycle pour
faire de la polémique mais je crois
qu'il a exprimée ce qu'une immense
majorité d'entre nous pensent c'est à
dire que ces touristes ont été
inconscient et je pense que c'était le
sens de sa question
il est temps que le gouvernement mette
en place une procédure très clair pour
inviter nos concitoyens qui veulent se
déplaçait à travers le monde et ça c'est
une liberté fondamentale mais de bien
comprendre que quand on va dans certains
endroits on risque sa vie déjà
personnellement et il n'est pas obligé
de faire risque est également celle de
ceux qui sont là pour nous défendre
certes mais dans des conditions autres
on va continuer ce débat non mais
vraiment et gonnehem on va parler aussi
de l'école puisque la loi bancaire est
examinée justement à tam tran et écouter
l'un elle est avec jean-michel bancaire
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
c'est à vous oui jean michel bancaire le
scénar inscrire dans votre projet de loi
l'interdiction de voile pour les
accompagnantes de sorties scolaires
il ya vous étiez contraint certains
amendements dans l'hémicycle pourtant
vous êtes personnellement opposée au
port du voile dans ses sorties scolaires
oui alors c'est pas évidemment le seul
sujet de cette loi on peut commencer par
par là mais je voudrais quand même dire
qu'il ya les apports du sénat je vais
vous répondre mais le fait majeur hier
c'est quand même que l'instruction
obligatoire à 3 ans a été voté à
l'unanimité
enfin ici je pense que c'est quand même
le premier point à souligner sur l'un
des éléments de ce qui s'est passé hier
il ya ce que vous venez de dire alors
évidemment je suis défavorable à ce qu'
il puisse y avoir des signes
ostentatoires et compris de la part des
parents néanmoins la question de savoir
si ça peut être une interdiction légale
ou si c'est une recommandation que nous
faisons
pour les sorties scolaires de la part
des directeurs d'école d'augmentation du
conseil d'état une position du conseil
d'état qui nous invite à apprendre cette
deuxième position donc comme vous le
savez je suis très engagé sur les sujets
de laïcité comme justement le bon
respect de la loi de 2004
veillez à ce qu'ils aient pas des actes
de prosélytisme ce qui est aussi quelque
chose qui a été voté hier d'ailleurs et
de façon plus générale combat pour la
laïcité c'est pour ça qu'on est apte à
l'aide et des équipes laïcité dans
chaque rectorat de france et donc sur
cette question du voile c'est presque un
point de droit de savoir s'ils vont
passer par la loi ou s'il faut résoudre
cela par l'action des directeurs je suis
évidemment à leur côté pour s'assurer
que il n'y ait pas de prosélytisme à
l'occasion des sorties scolaires n'est
pas par la loi
ainsi nous vous le disiez votre point
phare de votre projet doit donc a été
adopté hier à l'unanimité celle à
l'école obligatoire à 3 ans est-ce que
c'est autre chose qu'une mesure
symbolique on l'a dit et répété 97 % des
enfants sont aujourd'hui scolarisées et
savez vous combien d'enfants étaient
scolarisés quand il ya eu la loi de
jules ferry
orban en 1880 et c'était également une
très très large de leurs 2 93%
donc en réalité ce que nous nous
inscrivons dans cette grande trajectoire
historique que nous évidemment suivons
avec humilité mais qui consiste à poser
un cadre est derrière l'instruction
obligatoire à 3 ans il ya beaucoup de
choses
il ya ceux d'un point de vue très
directs une mesure sociale c'est à dire
ramener à l'école environ 25000 enfants
parce que c'est ça pour ça c'est ne sont
pas scolarisés actuellement donc c'est
déjà très important pour ses vingt-cinq
mille enfants là mais c'est aussi estimé
que l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans
signifie toute une série de conséquences
en chaîne
par exemple la visite médicale à trois
ans qui nous permet de détecter plus tôt
des troubles par exemple de l'oeil ou de
loïc qu'il faut détecter le plus tôt
possible
rien que ce point là est extrêmement
important c'est aussi s'assurer que
l'instruction à domicile et fait
convenablement quand elle a lieu à trois
ans plutôt que d'attendre 6 ans et de
tomber parfois sur sur des cas où les
choses ne se passent pas convenablement
en famille il ya donc toute une série de
conséquences de l'instruction
obligatoire à 3 ans et puis un grand
signal qui est envoyé qui est un signal
de soutien à l'école maternelle
ça consiste à dire l'école maternelle
c'est très important il faut prendre ça
très au sérieux même si c'est un endroit
toujours agréable dicks
anonyme de plaisir mais c'est évidemment
fondamental pour le développement de
l'enfant
que répondez vous à ceux qui jugent que
c'est un cadeau aux maternelles privées
puisque les communes vont devoir leur
verser de l'argent et certains jugent
que ces 150 millions d'euros qu'il ya 20
ans on leur être versée ceux qui disent
cela sont en général ceux qui cherchent
toujours à voir ce qui ne va pas et
quand on leur montre la lune
il regarde le doigt d'abord le ce que
vous venez de dire est la conséquence
logique juridique constitutionnel même
de l'instruction obligatoire à 3 ans qui
souvent d'ailleurs été prônée par les
partis politiques dont font partie des
personnes dont vous parlez donc il ya
même un petit paradoxe de ce point de
vue là et il est curieux d'ailleurs de
voir que des gouvernements précédents
nom l'ont pas fait précisément parce que
il
ils ont buté devant l'obstacle
l'obstacle c'est de compenser aux
collectivités locales
les frais supplémentaires qu'occasionne
l'instruction ne pas vous être engagé je
me suis engagé mais ça vaut pour les
écoles privées comme pour les écoles
publiques et bien mais je perds ma voix
dans les duels a exactement eu besoin
d'aller en avoir encore besoin jean
michel branquart puisque votre projet de
loi va être examiné dans quelques
instants et au moins jusqu'à demain soir
avant un vote solennel mardi prochain
merci beaucoup de sueur mitre d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
merci beaucoup te convient d'entendre le
ministre jean raymond hugonnet sur cette
instruction obligatoire dès l'âge de 3
ans elle faisait plutôt consensus et
pourtant il y avait cette question sur
le financement les collectivités
territoriales vont elles devoir un
supporter justement cette scolarité
obligatoire
alors forcément comme l'a dit jean
michel lancker le climat actuel peut
faire perdre les effets bénéfiques de
cette loi en tout cas
de la scolarisation à partir de 3 ans
pourquoi parce que à force de mentir au
maire à force de l'or quand on a eu la
conférence des territoires là à force de
leur annoncer des choses qui ne se
produisent pas et sans cesse de voir
leurs revenus baisser et le revenu de
leur commune bien sûr b c est bien les
élus à chaque fois qu'on bouge quelque
chose avec des lois qui sont souvent
bavarde et imprécises ils ont peur
justement donc cette cette fois-là cette
peur je pense que les amis des collègues
va permettre justement et bien d'apaiser
les choses on voit l'état et les
collectivités territoriales voilà c'est
en tout cas c'est en tout cas le sens de
nos remarques maintenant sur le sujet de
base jean-michel bancaire est revenu
dessus sur l'éducation obligatoire à
partir de 3 ans même si effectivement
quand on retire les territoires
d'outre-mer par exemple est content
quand la métropole
ça concerne relativement peu d'enfants
mais quand même c'est l'affirmation du
rôle des maternelles voilà ça je crois
que c'est une bonne chose
il ya eu des votes de la part de la
majorité sénatoriale suppression des
allocations familiales en cas
d'absentéisme des élèves il ya eu cette
question du port de signes religieux
pour les parents accompagnant les
sorties scolaires
c'était des amendements qui avaient déjà
qu'il y avait déjà des dispositions déjà
votées du temps d'eric ciotti supprimé
par la suite sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande
certains voient un retour d'une droite
réactionnaire alors bon voila moi je ne
suis pas dans les mots ces mots là la
droite réactionnaire conservatisme non
il faut redonner du sens aux mots un des
griefs que nous avons contre cette loi
c'est premièrement et l attaque par cet
article 20 sur l'exemplarité
ce que je veux dire alors où on annonce
clairement là les choses de la part du
ministre et du ministère en dix ans les
actuellement les professeurs ne sont pas
exemplaires et c'est à dire qu'ils ne
sont pas exemplaires
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
souhaité avec l'exemplarité renforcer
aussi l'autorité qui éteint ce n'est pas
un gros mot dans d'autres pays les
autorités
c'est même la base d'une éducation
reconnaître cette autorité quand vous
êtes élu local que vous avez l'occasion
de regarder des cahiers de
correspondante que vous présente les
enseignants dans un conseil d'école vous
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est pas
c'est la vraie vie et que vous voyez que
des enseignants se font insulter par des
parents par des parents qui donnent
forcément raison à l'enfant l'enfant roi
l'enfant s'est tous hâte une fadaise
vous compreniez il y a une autorité
qu'il faut restaurer un respect mutuel
bien évidemment mais il ya le respect
vis-à-vis de l'enseignant c'est
fondamental sur le port du voile
là encore on essaye d'attiser des
vieilles lunes
il ya une loi dans notre pays et là
dessus je rejoins le président de la
république qui a dit en terme de laïcité
la loi de 1905 ni plus ni moins quand on
la lit elle est parfaite
si l'on cherche à la contourner ou si on
commence à employer des adjectifs à ce
moment là on arrive à des situations que
l'on connaît aujourd'hui avec des choses
qui sont qu'il ne devrait pas avoir lieu
d'être
parce que des choses sont très claires
pas stigmatiser certaines familles jean
raymond et gonnet justement cet avis
aussi du conseil d'état fait qu'il ne
s'agit pas de stigmatiser des familles
il s'agit de dire dans notre pays
souvent on entend des hommes et des
femmes politiques d'hier
liberté égalité fraternité laïcité non
ce n'est pas une valeur
voyez ce que je veux dire de la
république c'est un principe et à partir
du moment où on sait ce que c'est que la
loi de 1905 et qu'on applique sans
chercher à la dévoyée il n'y a pas de
problème faut-il encore avoir le courage
de l'appliquer et de la lire
convenablement sans arrière-pensée alors
on va continuer cet entretien on va y
aller en parler des 80 km heure 1
puisque les ya la volonté est bien de la
part de l'exécutif d'assouplir cette
mesure pour en parler elle tentera
musette avec la sénatrice et l'ère des
alpes-maritimes madame et ça sonne
dominique estrosi sassone oui dominique
estrosi sassone votre réaction au fait
que le premier ministre lâche du lest
sur les 80 km/heure et qu'il accepte que
les conseils départementaux assoupli
cette mesure alors je serais beaucoup
plus réservé parce que ce qu'annonce le
premier ministre via un amendement
c'est une mesure trop à la maniabilité
effectivement l'action ausy en trompe
l'oeil c'est un semblant d'ouverture et
pour moi c'est toujours une mesure qui
montre que le gouvernement affiche un
véritable mépris envers les élus locaux
et qu'ils considèrent les élus locaux
comme potentiellement irresponsable
parce qu'en connaissant la possibilité
d'augmenter la vitesse maximale que aux
présidents des conseils départementaux
et non plus au préfet également et bien
cela reviendrait à pointer du doigt les
élus locaux et demain à les rendre
potentiellement responsables de tout
accident mortel
donc finalement on peut penser que très
peu très peu de leurs élus locaux
oseront franchir le pas et je pense que
il était beaucoup plus sain de continuer
à rester sur la position qu'a prises le
sénat qui est une position ni dogmatique
ni laxiste une position qui me semble
équilibré et surtout qui est suspendu
aussi à l'avis de la commission
départementale de la sécurité routière
puis on rappelle la position du sénat
s'était donné cette flexibilité aux
préfets et aux présidents de conseils
départementaux met effectivement en
fonction de la dangerosité des routes en
fait c'est bien ça le problème c'était
ça le problème c'était ça le problème
et c'est ce que le sénat a voulu mettre
en avant c'est à dire que personne ne
détient la vérité en matière de sécurité
routière
il s'agit pas de dire à tout le monde
aller plus vite mais il s'agit d'adapter
sa vitesse et pour ce faire
effectivement laissé là
possibilité sur les réseaux de routes
nationales et départementales soit au
président du conseil départemental soit
au préfet là on ne laisse plus que les
élus locaux en première ligne et je
pense que c'est extrêmement
préjudiciable et ça montre que c'est la
ligne
edouard philippe qui l'emporterait alors
que le président de la république après
le grand débat national avait laissé
véritablement la porte ouverte à un réel
assouplissement vous jugez que
finalement il un flipper avec cette
annonce est un petit peu perverti ce
qu'avait proposé le président de la
république lors du grand débat
oui je pense que dans philippe n'a rien
lâché au demeurant sur une décision qui
est une décision qui lui est personnelle
qu'il a voulu imposer est donc bien
évidemment sous laquelle il n'était pas
prêt à revenir
donc on trouve ce subterfuge mais qui me
semble être pas de nature
en tout cas à correspondre à la volonté
aux attentes des français mais aussi à
la volonté de continuer bien évidemment
à assurer à tout le monde
le meilleur niveau de sécurité possibles
personne n'était responsable à leur
matière et pas surtout pas les élus
locaux
justement il d'un philippe juge que cet
abaissement de la limitation de vitesse
a produit ses effets il fait valoir
les meilleurs la meilleure année en
terme de sécurité routière qu'est ce que
vous répondez sauf que quand il ya une
expérimentation on lui a demandé à
maintes reprises les chiffres ils n'ont
jamais été fournis et puis on peut dire
aussi que malheureusement aujourd'hui
elle le problème de la sécurité routière
c'est aussi un problème financier
et quand on affecte au budget de la
prévention routière uniquement 12
millions d'euros et seulement trente
mille euros
sur les deux milliards d'euros récoltés
par l'état sur les amendes qui sont
perçues après les donc infractions liées
aux radars et bien je trouve que c'est
là dessus que devrait se porter les
efforts du gouvernement mais pas
forcément sur des mesures qui sont des
mesures trop sévères trop ferme et qui
ne prennent pas en compte la réalité des
territoires en disant à tout le monde
que la mobilité est la même pour tout le
monde non elle n'est pas la même pour
tout le monde
eh bien merci à beaucoup dominique
estrosi sassone d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
merci beaucoup à temps pour cette
nouvelle réaction c'est un
assouplissement en trompe l'oeil ce que
propose le gouvernement sur les 80
kilomètres heure selon vous bien sûr ce
que ce que vient de dire dominique
estrosi sassone et est exactement fin je
pense exactement
ce qu'elle vient de dire mais encore une
fois on observe la même séquence
qu'est-ce qui a attrapé le gouvernement
et le premier ministre qui l'a défendu
dans l'hémicycle est vraiment avec force
qu'est ce qui leur a pris de toucher à
cela on ne disconvient pas la sécurité
routière les accidents c'est un objectif
de pouvoir pallier à ça mais quand même
qu'est-ce qu'on avait besoin dans le
climat actuel de notre pays de toucher à
cela on l'a dit de façon tout à fait on
n'était pas dans la lutte politique et
dans le dogme on l'a dit de façon c'est
l'expression des territoires notre
collègue michel raison a dit de façon
très posé que c'était une erreur et bien
le gouvernement s'est entêté et il a
fallu cet épisode d gilet jaune pour que
piteusement le président de la
république dans un espèce de 2-2-2
boubli ghoul gars disent on lâche du
lest sauf que le lest il est lesté fait
de lâcher comme le reste en trompe
l'oeil et encore une fois on va demander
aux collectivités de supporter les
dégâts de cette affaire le sénat
prévoyait de laisser justement le choix
à la fois président département mais
aussi au préfet c'est justement l'option
retenue
eh bien non mais pourquoi parce qu'avec
le préfet l'état était encore acteurs
donc c'est encore une fois un subterfuge
une sortie de cette crise que le
gouvernement a créé de toutes pièces
et encore une fois on aurait pu s'éviter
ce débat parce que ça fait un petit
moment quand même qu'on dit certes là
dessus alors on va continuer justement
d'analyser l'actualité parlementaire
avec nous et sans vraiment hugonnet
aujourd'hui c'était aussi la publication
d'un rapport très attendu sur
l'indépendance et l'objectivité des
agences de sécurité sanitaire avant sa
parution il avait fait polémique avec
les propos sont le glyphosate du
sénateur pierre médevielle je vous
propose d'écouter bien l'interview
accordée par gérard longuet vice
président de l'opecst ce à quoi on tend
calme et à écouter
oui général on guette le président de
l'opex on a vu cédric villani qui est le
premier vice président pour l'assemblée
nationale parler de cette émotion énorme
de ces derniers jours autour de la
polémique sur ce rapport qu'est-ce que
vous tirer comme enseignement vous de
ces derniers jours
il faut raccourcir le délai entre le
moment où l'office vote
l'adoption d'un rapport et le moment où
les rapporteurs communiqué à la presse
croit qu'il faut réduire le délai à
quelques heures et non pas qu'elle est
ce qu'il a commis un impair
le sénateur médevielle qui s'est exprimé
avant la remise du rapport sur la
question du glyphosate
il a parlé comme comme un homme
politique parle librement à son
journaliste local et c'est pas une
affaire d'état sauf qu'il a parlé du
glyphosate qui n'est pas sur le fond la
question qui est tranchée par ce rapport
et du coup il a pu sembler donner
l'impression que vous alopexx vous
alliez vous exprimer sur cette question
qui est compliqué dans l'opinion
qu'est ce que vous dites dans ce rapport
sur cette question du glyphosate et bien
que la façon d'examiner ce produit est
différente selon les agences que l'
agence qui dépendent le ms lui trouve
des caractéristiques de cancérigènes
possibles et les autres agences
européennes ne le trouve pas pourquoi
parce qu' elle ne travaille pas de la
même façon et ne se posent pas les mêmes
questions d'une certaine façon je
reconnaissant à pierre médevielle
d'avoir involontairement attirer
l'attention de l'opinion sur les
conditions de travail des agences
justement un dernier mot sur ces agences
parce que c'est là le fond de votre
travail dans ce rapport est-ce qu'il est
convenable
est ce qu'il ya de graves difficultés
dans la façon dont cette agence peuvent
communiquer leurs résultats l'opinion
publique non je crois simplement qu'il
faut que l'opinion puisse bénéficier de
ce que vous faites à cet instant c'est
d'ailleurs une formation complète une
information détaillée une information
mûri réfléchi et qu'il ne cherche pas le
sensationnel et qui aille au fond des
réalités du dossier merci beaucoup
gérard longuet a répondu à nos questions
sur l'antenne de public sénat
c'est beaucoup quand un agent vraiment
est bonne et on voit la difficulté
aujourd'hui finalement d'avoir et bien
un avis en 2019 sur la dangerosité sur
le caractère cancérogène ont pas du
glyphosate
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire alors ça
dépend à qui vous adresser aux
parlementaires je le suppose ou aux
français que je suis père de famille
parce qu'encore une fois on est dans un
débat qui est totalement biaisé on lâche
la vindicte populaire et à la
communication voilà le glyphosate c'est
devenu c'est le diable en personne ces
deux responsables de tous les maux il ya
tout voilà on fait des émissions ont
fait les cheveux ok alors qu' il y a des
organes qui sont là justement pour
essayer d'éclairer la vie des français
ces organes ont des avis différents
c'est bien le problème gens réellement
et bonnet lequel croire eh ben je vais
vous expliquer une chose moi très simple
dès qu'on parle d'experts je souris
pourquoi quel que soit le sujet que vous
entrepreniez chacun trouvera en fonction
des lobbys de ce qui représente de ce
qu'il croit trouvera l'expert l'expert
bardé de diplômes bien sous tous
rapports qui va lui passé moi
l'expression hupond dhr un rapport
indépendant
ce terme de lobby voilà exactement donc
ensuite le français qu'est ce qu'il voit
lui lit son journal il écoute la radio
il écoute voilà et il se fait son avis
de lui même sauf que son avis est biaisé
et par rapport à ça j'engage tout le
monde à faire ce que j'ai fait
modestement sur ma commune dont j'ai été
maire pendant 17 ans c'est tout
simplement quand il ya des agriculteurs
je suis en essonne sur une plaine
agricole très belle c'est d'ouvrir les
fermes d'ouvrir les fermes pour voir que
les agriculteurs ne sont pas de voeux le
capitaliste voyez ce que j'ignore
uniquement ils ont des enfants aussi des
agriculteurs
il manque jeu aussi un et jusqu'à plus
ample informé dans ce pays voilà l'âge
de décès est quand même repoussé
l'espérance de vie est quand même
repoussé ça veut dire quand même qu'il
ya eu certes un progrès mais si on veut
se faire une idée eh bien on n'a qu'à
les voir son agriculteur et j'engage des
élus moins à faire visiter les fermes et
à savoir comment travail des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui maintenant de
leur dire du jour au lendemain il ya un
produit qui est contestée pas contesté
mais en tout cas on peut pas nier qu'il
ya un problème dessus le retirer de la
sueur la france a cherché des solutions
de remplacement gerçures du glyphosate
donc il ya certainement urgence à
trouver un remplacement parce qu'il y a
un problème c'est indéniable mais mais
soyons juste un tout petit peu
raisonnable dans la démarche et c'est ce
qui me gêne
alors gérard longuet ont encore une fois
eu raison de s'exprimer comme ça je
pense qu'il faut être là dessus avec des
disques
science rennes éviter forcément ce qu
est un sport national dans notre pays de
cliver les pour les contre et de faire
monter tout ça pour faire de l'audience
tout ça n'est pas voyez ce que je veux
dire ça demande un débat quand même
beaucoup plus sérieux et approfondi que
c'est rapide
restez avec nous en donner on continue
cette galerie fin de notre séance de
questions d'actualité avec vous au
théâtre à nier le sénateur écologiste
rattaché au groupe et eps bernard jomier
il a interpellé le gouvernement
justement sur un fichier des gilets
jaunes lorsqu'ils sont aux urgences oui
effectivement vous avez interpellé tout
à l'heure l'exécutif sur cette question
du fichage des gilet jaune avec un
dévoiement du fichier civique
expliquez-nous exactement quel est le
problème aujourd'hui
écoutez le fichier civique c'est un
fichier qui est utilisé dans
circonstances exceptionnelles par
exemple après les attentats de novembre
2010 15 puisqu'il permet de collecter
des informations médicales et nominative
et de les transmettre à une autorité
extérieure
c'est donc une violation une dérogation
au secret médical
mais quand l'utilisent à d'autres fins
comme il a utilisé était utilisé à
propos des manifestations des gilets
jaunes
nous estimons qu'il ya un dévoiement de
l'utilisation de ce fichier il ya eu un
appel de 100 médecins très très connu
pour un nombre d'entre eux dont bernard
debré dont andré grimaldi dont irène
kahn-bensaude dont philippe de normandie
et qui rappelle que cette transmission
d'information médicale avec l'identité
des personnes est illégale et donc j'ai
interrogé la ministre pour lui demander
si elle allait diligenter une enquête
indépendante pour tirer au clair ce qui
s'est passé et vous n'avez pas été
satisfait par la réponse de christelle
du boss
elle a jugé qu'il y avait eu un simple
malentendu et que simplement on avait
repéré les victimes
en marge des manifestations de gilet
jaune etc tout cela ne s'apparentaient
pas un fichage quand vous mettez
ensemble des données nominatives et des
données médicales que vous les collecter
vous voulez transmettez ça s'appelle un
fichier voilà alors après on n'est pas
obligé pensée qui va être mal utilisé
mais de toute façon c'est illégal en
termes de santé et malheureusement
1 une enquête a été diligentée m'est
confiée aux hôpitaux qui aurait commis
la faute donc c'est quand même un
principe extraordinaire de droit de
réponse de confier les enquêtes à celui
qui est supposé avoir commis l'acte
délictueux et deuxièmement on constate
qu'il ya un autre fichier sanitaire
celui des patients hospitalisés en
psychiatrie au contre leur consentement
qui a été croisée par autorisation
décret de la ministre avec un fichier du
ministère de l'intérieur
et à chaque fois avec un avis
défavorable de la commission nationale
de l'informatique et des libertés
et c'est ça qui nous interrogent
particulièrement c'est que le
gouvernement ne respecte pas les avis de
la cnil en la matière et notamment pour
la suite effectivement pour toute la
numérisation des données de santé c'est
exactement études pour tout à fait eh
bien merci beaucoup bernard jomier
d'avoir répondu à ces questions
merci à vous tam jean-raymond hugo n'est
l'examen de la loi bancaire se poursuit
dans l'hémicycle on ira voir alexandre
tout ça dans un instant vous vouliez
évoqué cet article ces squatters un qui
me permettait le regroupement
d'établissements primaires avec des
collèges pour bien créer ces
établissements publics des savoirs
fondamentaux article supprimé en
commission vous êtes satisfait c'est
révélateur
c'est révélateur d'une chose cette loi
pour une école de la confiance alors on
nous refait le coup passez moi
l'expression encore une fois mais du mot
confiance ça fait trois fois que le
gouvernement le fait le plus drôle si
c'était pas à pleurer c'est c'était la
loi pour une société de confiance qui
est une espèce de baudruche vide de sens
là on nous refait le coup avec
l'éducation alors le problème c'est que
vous avez dans cette loi un article qui
phagocyte tout le reste et jean michel
blanquer rabbo s'est escrimé à essayer
de dire qu'il ya autre chose dans ce
texte non c'est l'article 6 quater et
croyez-moi quand on a été élu local
et quand votre téléphone explose parce
que tous les parents vous appelle en
même temps et les enseignants en même
temps qu'ils soient de droite de gauche
du centre de partout c'est qu'il ya un
problème
or il ya un problème profond et
maintenant nous sommes nous devant cette
cette question l'article 6 quater nous
l'avons supprimer notre collègue jacques
grosperrin a préparé avec d'autres une
réécriture qui verrouille le tout mais
ça verrouille tellement le tout
à ce moment là ça n'a plus de sens moi
je suis véritablement plus qu'agacé de
cette affaire-là pourquoi parce que si
on voulait traiter le problème de base
qui est le vrai problème c'est à dire le
passage du cycle 20 au collège à ce
moment là il fallait s'y prendre
autrement
hélas le ministre ses prix de façon
incroyable les pieds dans le tapis et
bien merci merci beaucoup genre et moi
et vous venez d'être venu en plateau sur
pu merci
c'est la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi très bonne suite
des programmes sur notre antenne
[Musique]